You are listening to radio lab radio from W N Y.
S C e. Yup.
That lime doesn't cut it very much, I guess. Really powerful.
It's basically straight rum. Yeah. This is a very,
a traditional Guadalupe Ian drink called that tea punch as in punch as in punch.
Uh, ready. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab.
Today we're going to go off to an island. Yeah.
Small little corner of the globe,
which in its very surprising way is trying to figure out how to understand
itself. Buffet itself and protect itself against the winds of the wider world.
Yeah, exactly.
Comes to us from our reporter Simon Adler. So, uh,
I went to Guadeloupe a couple, a couple of weeks back,
which is this French overseas department. Basically a territory from
Guadalupe. Guadalupe is a, this series of islands in the Caribbean,
bit east of Puerto Rico and 400 miles north of Venezuela. More or less.
Okay. So just landed the runway we landed on here was a,
it was just a bordered on both sides by these super lush green walls of,
of flora. I have no idea what they were.
And the story I want to tell actually starts on a watermelon farm.
It's okay if I park here, owned by this couple,
celly and Lois, thank you so much for being willing to do this.
They look to be in their late forties. Let's pull him.
How many celly had on a pair of glasses,
tee shirt and a cutoff blue jeans and just into the,
my wife and Lois. Nice to meet you. Very nice to me.
She was wearing one of those floppy hats and big rubber boots.
So you, you were born here in Guadalupe? Yeah.
It was only granted ops in what parts? It was born in print.
So after growing up in Guadalupe and graduating, Sally decided to, uh,
to get off the island for a bit. Went overseas for work and gay on eyes.
It was a executor's Ghana met Lois soul and fell in love.
It's true. Anyway, Zen, I came back to Guadalupe 20 years ago, uh,
to establish myself in the area. Did you buy this farm right here? I truly,
I didn't buy it. That I know was in the family for a long time. Okay.
So I decided just to give them a a hundred and then we ended up staying.
So, you know,
so it wasn't planned that you would be towed another time and eventually they
kinda fell in love with farming. We enjoyed. So it's a,
it's a new and different, a way of living. You know,
they've got like 60 acres of land.
These rolling hills bordered by the ocean filled with their crops.
Still mantles a sweet peppers. Bumpkins and watermelons,
watermelons. Our main [inaudible]. Yeah. So, uh,
Sally Louis took me out to their actual farm. So this is the, oops,
these are what we have to have it still in there. In this field.
I was surrounded by just hundreds and hundreds of these enormous watermelon or
these are huge, like, yes, they weigh about 20 to 25 pounds.
And this was actually why I was there because these watermelon in this field for
the past 15 years had been under attack. This one,
this one is another one that was punctured and this one is fresh.
Oh Man. Okay. This, they, they've been here recently? Yes. Likely last night.
Still red. It's still fresh.
And there's this golf ball sized hole board into the side of it.
It has a high amateur of maybe two inches,
and the watermelon itself had had just been emptied out.
It's incredible. It's like the deflated ball and you walk on it.
It's the same thing and the same thing and the same thing.
This field was just littered with hollow water. This,
this is the worst attack we've had in about three years because as I said,
they did it specially because you were coming.
I want you to ask this cause I think it's time. Who or what is doing all this?
Raccoons. Raccoons. Raccoon rack of course records.
Those masked bandits with the,
with those little tiny hands and the adorable.
Adorable at all. So not cute. No, no one. No.
But even if you think they're horrible, you have to give them that.
They are clever. Yeah, they were.
They were sneaking into Sali and Louis' field at night finding the biggest
rapist. Watermelon in the patch. Boring a tiny hole into it.
Scraping out the juicy innards. They just scoop it out and chowing down.
It's a fiesta. And for, and Lewis, this was a huge problem. UOP stuff. Anyway.
[inaudible] you're able to lose a a third of it.
A third of the watermelon crop would just be yes.
Meaning it could go up to a 20% of your venue. Yeah, sure.
Thousands of dollars. So we couldn't stand this loss is too much now.
We had to do something. We had to fight. So what do they do? What's that?
15 years ago, a sully and Lois declare war. Meaning what?
Well, to start with, we put any electric fence around our field, Zap them,
keep 'em away pretty quick in north to put the branch and walk on the branch and
get into your field anyway, they built a third of bridge.
You mean they would walk over the branches? Yeah.
So then they've got to try something new this time. They're like,
we have to be [inaudible] at night chasing them a blast music at them.
We'll run around.
We've lads who sad with Nordic with at one point [inaudible] even a stoop to
just throwing rocks at the raccoons. He picked up a rock and just,
I'm a good a belter, but you can stay in the field all night long.
So next thing they decided to try is, okay, let,
let's put some traps out in the field. Oh, we tried to trap some with Zillow,
smell these big metal third a trip wire cages.
But one day there was no trap.
We found a trapper in the woods and it was all bent up. They,
they run away with the truth. The trap. Yes.
The raccoons were actually destroying sometimes we just to TMC hoe shocks.
So for their final attempt, they decided, okay, you had to try the dogs,
guard dogs, put guard dogs in the field. But the next day when we came, it was,
it was, it was, it was a massacre.
The raccoons killed one of your dog. Exactly.
All of his intestines were outside. So it was a jewel to the debt. Oh,
well yeah. Really. So you know what kind of animal you're dealing with.
This confirms every feeling I have about racquets. They are not just clever.
They're fierce and inward. There's good and bad in every one of them.
These were obviously not very nice. Raccoons in the shower,
Lewis and Sally's position, I course I would shoot these records.
Is that what they did well or poison them something? Well,
yet I thought that if anybody would be on board with, uh,
with some sort of a eradication campaign,
it would be value in Lewis. Right? But when I floated this idea by them,
if I was you, I would want to kill those raccoons.
They just kind of looked at me funny
killing them. Uh, it's a little, uh, a little harsh,
but they're, they're attacking your livelihood. Yes. Yeah. They just,
it's hard to, I'm trying to understand how you,
I know it sounds strange because I myself putting myself in your position.
I would find it strange too. It's just maybe a sentimental,
a feeling, you know? Wait, W why, why mental feelings?
What does that mean? Well,
here's the thing. The people of Guadalupe,
they acknowledged that these raccoons are super destructive.
They know that they are attacking not only watermelon farms but but goat farms
and chicken farms that they're going and tipping over trash cans in downtown
[inaudible] but, but yet simultaneously the
door them [inaudible] just very loved Salafi. Of course we love the raccoons.
They put them on their postcard. We just think it's so cute.
It's driving down their main highways.
You see billboards where people's logos for their advertisement for their,
for their tire company is the raccoon. Like it's everywhere.
There is a statue of Iraq coat at the zoo with Ben Vinu zoo,
the grow newt. They're the number one exhibit here.
They are the first thing you see when you walk in,
we have menus in the trees there. Wow.
Couple up there like monkey and on the way out of the zoo,
all of you when you walk into the gift shop,
got a Coffee Cup with the raccoon on it. A snow globe with a record in it.
Key chains might have to get rid of those people love the record
people. People are raccoon crazy on this island. Why? Well it's,
it's really complicated. It. It has to do with their history of the island.
It has to do with who came to the island,
when and who gets to say what happens on the island. It has to do with with,
with power. Like who are you talking about? A raccoon here. That's still,
all of these problems and ideas are, are inside the raccoons tail. In fact,
in this, in his tail, the tail of the raccoon and the tail about the Raco. Yeah.
What [inaudible] as far as explain this a little better.
The trouble all started DVDs,
any mean of song in 1911 with this guy, Garrett Miller,
he was a scientist working at the national museum in DC or museum Mu Muleeka
despite the way is blending chemo. She works for the wildlife.
Police spoke to my interpreter, Sally, Stan Yan, and she told us one day,
Miller was just hanging out in his office when a box showed up from quite a loop
and he opened it up and found how queen mill, very much dead raccoon. Yeah.
That's sort of misshapen, uh, skin and that can accompanying skull.
This is a Christopher Halligan curator of mammals at the National Museum of
natural history.
Part of the Smithsonian institution actually has the same job that Miller had
back in 1911. Anyway, uh,
this raccoon that Miller had in front of him looked a lot like the North
American raccoon,
but it was small and different in quite subtle ways.
And so after some inspection, Miller baptized to go to the Pea,
raccoons at distinct species,
scientific name [inaudible] precise and minor [inaudible],
the Guadalupe and raccoon putting a name on it and recognizing it as a new
species implied a deep history of the presence of raccoons in Guadalupe,
hundreds of thousands, if not millions of years. And over these millennia,
these raccoons had evolved into their own distinct species,
found nowhere else on the planet. So is that when the Guadalupe,
Ian's began to love raccoons when they realized they had their own, you know,
one and only. Yeah, but, uh, well it took a while to catch on. I mean, um,
this discovery was,
was initially only being talked about in these arcane academic scientific
journals. It's not like this discovery with on the,
with on the front page of the Guadalupe Aeon Times or anything. Uh, but then,
uh, in the 1980s, you know,
conservation really came into its own scientists started worrying about, uh,
about species disappearing from the planet and in particular they started
worrying about this raccoon, these raccoons, you know,
we're being recognized as potentially endangered thought being there only on
these islands. There probably aren't that many of them. Like we've,
we've got to protect these things.
[inaudible] and so el that [inaudible] since Guadalupe is an overseas French
department, France decided to do just that.
February 17th, 1989 legislation, uh,
was created to protect the raccoon and shortly after the passage of this,
do they do he look back no sooner do like with loop
[inaudible] loop opened up its first
national park and uh, the raccoon became the mascot,
the symbol of the national park.
And then you met [inaudible] and as the mascot of this new national park
[inaudible] it really became that symbol of protecting species [inaudible] loop.
It was celebrated apple predestined. People were like, okay, nice.
We love the raccoon in Morrison.
Then just a symbol of the importance of protecting the natural environment of
Guadalupe. Over time, the raccoon became in a way,
a symbol of Guadalupe itself. What was it? As you knew,
it's really that symbol for people that you can definitely see it as the old
evil in the u s
aside from raccoons,
you didn't really have hardly any other mammals that are native to these islands
apart from bats.
And so if the raccoon is the one furry critter running around that everyone can
point to and say, this is something special. You know,
this is not the same as a raccoon you'd find anywhere else. Um,
that is an exciting thing is a powerful thing. And uh, a point of pride I think.
Well, I mean we're not late in this time zone. Okay. Come in.
Okay. Nah, Nah,
and very good to meet you. How are you,
who's happy lodge now launched valley shows. No age doesn't help things.
This is not Marie Joseph and you, you were born here in Guadalupe.
We, yes, yes indeed. She is an older woman.
Maybe in her seventies wearing this pink floral dress.
Her house was right on the highway with a field in the back and that she says is
a, is where the raccoons would hang up. Huh. Please. Young men,
there was a whole bunch of them just like chilling in the area because all this
behind the house was sugar cane.
They actually came and fed on the sugar cane. Did you say, oh please.
[inaudible] out there. I loved seeing them.
I mean there was always some time of pleasure and excitement like seeing those
raccoons out there.
So patella and at some point there was one that we really became acquainted with
at that point. She, uh,
scooched her chair over and picked up this black and white photo that was,
that was sitting on her dining room table and inspected it. When can,
can I see the photo that you have here is crushed, filled with water.
[inaudible]
basically what's on the picture is Sophie and I'm feeding her bread that I
didn't, two milk.
Sophie was a pet raccoon that na had back in the late eighties upper pluck home
saw. And she talked about Sofi as if she were her child. Maybe they'll make
[inaudible] you let the Nidos that you're making the gesture of like cradling a
baby. [inaudible] Sophie
[inaudible],
Sophie [inaudible] he would run around and like every time I called her name and
everything, like she would just like come running. Yeah. Of MTV one Sophie.
I was really close to him and like when other people came to visit,
they could see that had this rare wild animal with me.
Uh,
and at one point she got,
she got really quiet a to Sufi and grasped the photo very tightly.
So you're holding it to your heart
better football debut. When he died, I cried.
I cried. His name too is really, really painful time for me.
[inaudible] a lot. It's important sometimes to have something of your own.
[inaudible]
I almost got the sense that having this raccoon as its national animal was a way
for Guadalupe to distinguish itself from France. What do you mean? Oh,
so Guadalupe has always been pushing against France,
trying to declare some sort of a cultural or national independence.
In fact, just a couple of years before this, uh, this law was [inaudible]
pass a group called the Guadalupe Liberation Army.
This group that was fighting for independence from France blew up a section of
Guadalupe airport and the last studio in the government own TV station,
even a Chanel fashion perfume store in central Paris,
[inaudible] tore out windows and doors and left him racks of high fashion
clothing and shreds.
And it felt to me like in some small way, uh,
the raccoon had become a way for the Guadalupe eons
to say to France, this is ours, not yours.
And because of that,
it also became a point of tension between France and Guadalupe.
Yeah. What do you, what do you mean by that? Well, um,
the morning after I met up with na, I went to this police.
Oh, good to see you to talk to these police officers.
Do you mind saying your name for me? [inaudible] mono.
Antoni Antony [inaudible] is mixed
[inaudible] as well as a couple of others. All of them,
but one were white and French. Uh,
they were stationed here in Guadalupe and the,
they took us up into this sort of war room, which was a,
the second story of this bungalow type building out in the middle of the jungle
oak hill. Uh, I'm looking a Subaru loop that has shown these things.
Everybody was sitting around this makeshift board room table
and okay. Pretty quick.
Uh, after the meeting started, they, they booted up this power.
The point is they've got a PowerPoint up with a picture of a raccoon displayed
up against the wall here. This image of a raccoon
crouched down in this chicken wire cage. Wait, so what's going on?
What is going on here? Well, their planning arrayed
to liberate this raccoon. In fact,
they had the location where it was being held, mapped out with,
with entry points designated. Uh,
they even had the license plate number of the man believed to be holding the
raccoon. And why exactly are they doing this?
Well because as Anthony [inaudible], the,
the leader of this whole operation explained to me in most of the space before
the law passed in France back in 1989 declaring the raccoon as a protected
species, it specifically outlawed killing raccoons,
transporting raccoons, and even [inaudible]
having raccoons for pleasure. You can't raise a raccoon as your own pet.
[inaudible] funny years, sometimes we're taking away a child of the family,
literally
[inaudible] but in France the law says they can't be held as pets [inaudible]
policy. And as a police officer in here, I'm speaking as a police officer,
I have to be here between 40 to law period. No questions asked.
And so once the briefing was over, they headed outside,
strapped their pistols to their belts through the rest of the gear in the back
of these SUVs and took off.
Everyone is rolling out. We're in three vehicles and 20 minutes later
we arrive at the top of this hill,
peering down into this lush dense jungle.
We're walking down this driveway into the forest.
We get halfway down the hill and, uh, w w w what are you?
Someone here? You did it up. Yeah. Apparently somebody who's in this clearing,
we spot this man. He doesn't see us.
There's a guy in a red shirt with a camouflage hat on.
He's got his hand behind his back. The cops tell us it's too dangerous.
You guys can't go any further. And so Sally and I ducked behind some trees
and then Simone and Anthony wearing a wireless microphone rushing to the
clearing to confront him. [inaudible] set up [inaudible] okay.
Anthony's started grilling him a bit. I'm going to say
[inaudible] me go ask him if he knew about the lot and they said he did.
[inaudible] call me and even though I was like 30 yards away,
I could see that the guy just seemed confused.
[inaudible] pretty harmless. All good here.
He's cooperating right away. Closer please, please.
He told them where the raccoon was. Oh,
there he is in this chicken wire cage behind this giant tree. Cute little guy.
This rough looking raccoon. They pull out a toolbox, wire cutters.
Raccoon is grabbing the wire cutter like you thought it was playtime or
dinnertime. They cut open. The cage reached into it.
These thick leather gloves that's on fire and then they granted by the neck and
threw it into this kind of dog carrier box thing and wait,
Mr to the mission is a success. [inaudible] create,
copy it with the 20th swimmingly as you know, you can get,
I gotta say this whole thing sounds a little, I don't know a little much for,
for this, for just releasing a pet. Yeah, no, agreed. But uh,
we're going to go put basically, okay.
Later that morning we went on this second rate. What are we expecting from,
from this scenario? And the seriousness clicked into place for me to,
I don't want to blame. I'll put this up here. It's really a different setting.
We walked into this courtyard surrounded by maybe 10 houses, uh,
many of them made of sheet metal.
And do we know where the raccoon is supposed to be? [inaudible]
it's right there under those trees.
He pointed at this pile of trash throwing this enormous white cage and their
inside was this golden looking raccoon. You had the
[inaudible] did. There's houses all around.
So we need to see who is really in charge of this raccoon.
But before the officers could do anything to free it room, I got the boys.
You have a crowd start together [inaudible] no, no, no, no.
W o a woman has just arrived. [inaudible] and basically what's going on?
Three or four people showed up, head started poking out of windows
[inaudible] and Sally overheard one of them saying that someone snitched and
said that there was a raccoon in the area. He said someone snitched. Yes.
And I suddenly realized that be all of the officers were, were very on edge.
[inaudible] just going to leave. Why can't we just,
just take the raccoon just for safety reasons.
They don't want to stay here too long. And we got outta there.
So d did t tell me what was going on in that second situation? Cause I,
I have a lot of, it was over my head. I mean it's really understanding the,
the context, the setting. I mean, this is not just a police,
I mean it's white police forces coming into an overwhelmingly black and poor
neighborhood that has a lot of, you know, significance in this context.
A Millennium News. Yeah. Oh wait. In fact,
when I was talking to na about this the night before, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no. She said that if police officers had ever come to try to take Sophie
[inaudible], I mean they would have had to take me in as well.
[inaudible] I would've taken my, my husband's gone and I would've, you know,
I would've shot
when we come back from break, the tail thickens,
we'll be right back.
This is Timothy calling from Stillwater,
Minnesota.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org.
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab and we're back with reporters. Simon Adler.
He's telling us the story of the Guadalupe Ian Raccoon,
which as we just heard for the people of Guadalupe is both a point of pride and
a point of tension.
We are in the back rooms are beyond the public areas. Exactly.
And to understand what happens next,
we're going up to the sixth floor of the museum.
We have to go to the Smithsonian Museum of Natural History here in the u s with
mammalogy [inaudible] Christopher Helga.
Where we are now is what's called the type collection,
the world's largest library essentially of dead mammals.
I have to say for such a grand place, it's,
it's a little visually underwhelming.
Basically just a bunch of locked white cabinets. But that said, um,
the behind the scenes area where you know, the real treasures are stored.
Can we take a quick detour so I can explain what he means by that? [inaudible]
sure. Okay.
So scientists taxonomists their job is to name and differentiate species,
right? So how did they do that? Well, uh, let's,
let's talk about sharks because sharks are kind of cool animals, right?
Imagine there's the shark species, it's swimming around.
It's having a great time. And, uh, at some point,
half of the sharks in this shark population decide to leave to go somewhere
else. I don't know. They go to deeper waters or to a different ocean.
They get cut off from the, their previous shark family.
They don't see them for a long time and over thousands or maybe a million years,
they actually start evolving on their own as sort of a new, uh,
a new type of shark has become different enough that they've become a new
species. That's what the scientists come in and try to figure out.
Now, how do they make that termination? Well,
so basically it's a comparison game. They compare them to the old sharks.
Do they look the same or their dorsal fins taller or shorter?
They'll look at how they, uh, how they behave in the water.
How they move through the world is that different nowadays they'll even just do
genetic work and if they decided it is in new species of shark
at that point, they do this sort of wacky thing that I had no idea about. Uh,
once they've decided that this, this shark is a new species,
scientists will go and kill one of these sharks. They will stuff it,
put it in a box and then they will store it in a locked cabinet in a natural
history museum somewhere.
Because ever after for hundreds of years,
that specimen becomes kind of a gold standard.
The definition of that species,
there's a different key for types than others. We just, uh,
every kind of moth or might or malice or mammal, you know,
every oak tree, every kind of zebra,
somewhere in the world there is a museum cabinet where locked down there is a
physical specimen of that organism. So it's like,
it literally is like the natural museum histories of the world or like the
library, the card catalog can't live life. Yeah. And the room that, uh,
that Helgen took me into in the sixth floor of the Smithsonian, I,
it was just cabinet after cabinet after cabinet after cabinet filled with these
type specimens, including the Guadalupe Raccoon type specimen.
The very specimen Miller inspected back in 1911.
So here are where you go.
Halligan bent down and opened this one particular cabinet and pulling out a big
metal drawer. And inside here, this is it right here.
Here it is right in front of you.
This sort of ratty looking taxidermy drack whom is maybe not the most pretty
site. You know, the ears are a little bit broken and bitten off. Uh,
some of the stuffing was coming out of the belly,
but that's probably how it arrived. Nope. Helgen for saw this raccoon, uh,
back in 2001 of the first things he did was turned it over and looked at it and
it's small, maybe like an 18 inches long like that,
that just like Miller had reported.
But then he popped open this little white box that had the skull in it and take
a look. What do you see here?
He pointed at these fine white lines crisscrossing the dome.
These are open sutures, which show that the skull is still growing.
In other words, it's not an adult,
which to Halligan was a big deal because ever since being a kid he was
suspicious of the Guadeloupe Ian Raccoon. It didn't, it didn't add up to me.
I just had a suspicion of, you know, these Caribbean raccoons didn't make sense.
He said, if you look at islands,
they usually don't have just one native mammal species walking around.
This made Guadeloupe an outlier. And so I'm going to put it on this tray.
The fact that this thing was a kid, it meant that there was nothing special,
at least about its size. And, um, you know, by the time I,
I laid my hands on this one and looked at the skin and skull,
I'd seen so many raccoons in museum collections that, you know,
I knew their skulls and teeth really well.
And so when I saw this and one of the first things I noticed is there was just
nothing that looked any different to me from the common raccoon in the North
American raccoon. And so Halligan decided to do some genetic work.
He compared the DNA of these Guadalupe and raccoons against North American ones
did the math. We made the comparisons. And, uh, our clear answer came through,
not only are these, you know, not very different,
they are just simply North American raccoons.
Looping records are the same ones that come in and torment my garbage cans.
He exact same raccoon.
He y'all common literally garden variety rack here and that we have in our own
backyard now for scientists and conservationists.
It is a real turnabout, you know, it goes from being distinct,
special, endemic, you know, found nowhere else to just the opposite
invasive species.
So when Halligan started publishing papers on the raccoon in 2002 a
conservationist, we're excited because raccoons, they can have real impacts.
They will do things like eat sea turtles, birds, nests, bird eggs,
including of some that are um, potentially endangered. They'll eat that. Wait,
they were, they were hurting actual endangered species. Um, yeah.
And so now that, now that they have proof,
now that they are certain that this raccoon doesn't belong here,
then they feel finally we're going to be able to go out and start doing
something about this. Protect the actually special lens. Get rid of this one.
Uh, sort of faker. But, uh,
putting conservation aside, what you've got is,
is this native to the island national icon animal that has suddenly become an
interloper brought there within the last, you know,
200 years probably just on a boat. Huh. Well,
we'll give it everything that you've told us about the colonial history.
How did the Guadeloupe eons react to this? Well, well, we went down, uh,
in 2004, Helga and his mentor to Guadalupe,
and we talked to some people associated with the zoo and with the government
management of the park. And it was just a very brief conversation.
He made sure that they had heard the news, you know, guys,
this raccoon that's found only in your country.
It's not what you thought it was and it doesn't belong here. And,
um, I remember that the message that came back to us was essentially,
thank you very much, but, uh, we're going to,
we're going to hold onto our record.
[inaudible]
Yep. Tolkien, Mondo communicates meaning according to Blondin Chemo,
there was no major communication campaign held on to make sure that the
population knew that there was a change in status.
The government never really told anyone. Uh, and when someone did say something
[inaudible] like Gerard Barry here
[inaudible] he's a native Guadalupe
Pian Longtime Conservation Amy [inaudible] music.
[inaudible] a few years back I was interviewed by a reporter and I told him what
I knew for a fact, uh,
when I read [inaudible] and everyone was just saying,
know off with his heads. Some of my friends were like,
why don't you put judicial [inaudible]? How could you possibly say this?
You know, you should not have said this. This is this bad.
And so for over a decade now, nothing has changed. Um,
the laws haven't been amended and because the governments kept this so hush hush
many people, these islands still
don't know the truth.
So my understanding of the story is for many, many years,
there was this thought that in fact,
I accidentally broke the news to not very recently.
It was discovered that no, in fact, it's a,
it's the same species that lives in the United States. Does that,
does that change your feelings about Sophie or about, uh, the,
the Guadeloupe Ian Raccoon in general. Is Your [inaudible]
[inaudible]
uh, was it at uni? [inaudible] up.
I can find it in the United States, but we wait,
so is it possible that maybe it was brought to the United States?
The scientists say that it was brought here from the United States? Your
[inaudible]? I mean,
I always thought that the raccoon was really endemic to Guadalupe in the
[inaudible].
It is kind of sad for me to know that it's not endemic to what loop. I mean,
no, I wish it would have been so to be honest.
And then, um,
I had the even less enviable task of informing,
not that just this past July
[inaudible] the EU passed this regulation.
We recognize that we cannot act on basically a black list of invasive species
whose negative impacts concern the European Union.
The thing is, uh, particularly in Germany, the raccoon is terribly invasive.
Uh,
these raccoons have actually been called the Nazi raccoons is they spread from
Germany throughout the continent. And so the raccoon made the list.
And that means that that members states like France and us,
very likely overseas agencies like Guadalupe will have to start managing or even
or advocating them from the folks I've spoken with.
There's a good possibility that in the next year the raccoon is going to change
from being a protected species to being a species that can be hunted,
trapped and killed.
Just keep it jockey boy 20 [inaudible] chassis [inaudible] attack.
Oh No, no, no.
[inaudible] [inaudible] there's some of him. [inaudible] it kills me.
Some of the, it kills me. The thought that, you know,
people could start hunting raccoons, like we have to protect them. Ah, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no. Uh, no, no, no.
A just show fee. It's not a specific, yeah.
Okay. Got It. I just don't care.
Angelic Charlotte, owner of the Guadalupe suit. You don't care? No,
I don't care. It's just the raccoon of Guadalupe. But it's kind of an imposter,
isn't it? It kind of tricked everyone, didn't it?
Here's one that's responsible of the person. I'm saying it was another specie.
People make an error. He didn't do anything.
You must respect to the animal, you know, uh,
even celly and Lois,
the watermelon farmers from the beginning of this story said,
at the end of the day, if, uh, let's say they say, okay, as of this date,
the raccoons are no longer, uh, whatever.
I don't see myself taking a rifle run into the field and just laying in,
wait to shoot them. No. It shows that, uh, we have, uh,
a few type of a wildlife, you know, no snake, nothing.
So, you know, is, uh, the bigger ones, the biggest one.
So people adopted it as a national animal. That's it. It's one of those,
if you can't be with the one you love, love the one you're with, type fit
could be a good one. So,
as a pragmatic person, I know it's an invite this patient today. I know it,
but I know also, I think he's cute and I think I like it.
So what is the best balance to find? You see,
I don't know.
[inaudible]
it's kind of interesting that, uh, we in America loved the Bald Eagle, uh,
kind of a wretched bird that steals other people's nests and is generally a
vulgar animal actually,
but we never think of it that way because we've given it majesty and we give it,
you know, in its talons there you see both, you know, peace and war.
It has been,
we've dressed it in America and I think every time a nation chooses to identify
with some wild thing.
It's mostly really about the people identifying not about the animal. Yeah,
I totally agree. But I see, I see like this,
like there's like you have this fact, right, there is a fact here that,
that the raccoons didn't show up a million years ago or whatever. Right?
It's probably, it was probably more like 200 years. That's most probably a fact.
Yeah. But then there's the stuff on top of that,
which is like is are they natural? Are they invasive?
Do they belong here? Those don't feel like facts.
Let's be like judgements and like who gets to make those judgements?
The scientist, I don't know.
I certainly didn't realize the extent that this was a deep seated cultural
battle in which I was, you know, entering with inserted yourself. Yes. Strongly.
Again, Christopher Helga is just a, the same information, you know,
different responses. And, um,
and I think that one of the deep questions of that,
of this story lives in that which is like you,
you came to a scientific truth and
the question becomes, should that scientific truth win the day?
I mean, uh, as a scientist, you know, I would say yes.
As a conservation biologist, I would say yes,
that's important to shows us that taxonomy really matters.
This animal didn't belong and, um, you know, really,
perhaps it should be removed from the island, but at the same time,
it's really a question for Guadeloupe. No, this is their island.
These are their animals running around on it. And, uh, um,
it can be very challenging for scientists like myself to come to terms with,
but that's how the world works.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
one more thought before we, uh, before we go. Is that all right? Um,
before Helgen officially sank or dethroned, uh,
this Guadalupe Ian Raccoon, there's actually another guy with a similar hunch.
Uh, this Parisian mammalogy just named a j m pawns.
And in one of his papers he wrote that even if it can be proven that the
Guadeloupe Ian Raccoon is no different from the North American raccoon.
That the best answer might not be it's reclassification or eradication,
but instead it's isolation.
He wrote that it's quote,
insular distribution prevents gene exchange with the mainland and is likely to
warrant different selective pressures that should favor short term genetic
differentiation that may lead to a longterm speciation process.
Wait, what does that mean?
Meaning if they were able to keep these North American raccoons on Guadalupe
isolated long enough, maybe some [inaudible]
they could be reclassified yet again this time as real,
quite a in [inaudible].
Yeah. What's your response to that?
Ponds said that. Um, but uh, you know, I like it, but uh,
uh, I have to say, you're going to be waiting a long time
that's going to take over.
[inaudible]
do you want to give super, super thanks to Sally,
Stan [inaudible] who was our translator and got Simon everywhere he needed to go
and made sure that it all worked out and do Allie panell here in New York who
helped make sense of the whole
thing before we left so, so we'll have a huge debt. Thanks also to Ebay manual.
David Xavier Owl bear, Lawrence Baptist,
sell them all and Florian Kirschner and to Bernie bean meal and most especially
thanks to Simon Adler who reported and produced the whole story here.
I want to read you go to this one paragraph real quick.
Can we before we go sign off about what,
cause you know how we were arguing about whether the raccoon is a good creature
or an immoral creature.
And I was looking for ammunition on the Internet to find,
to read to you guys and I found this thing,
I found this thing is it's in a blog called the truth about raccoons. Oh boy.
And it contains this paragraph, which I'm pretty sure is not true.
It goes, and I quote,
raccoons are one of the only land mammals who can also walk on the bottom of
river beds, holding their breath for up to an hour that they eat, both live,
pray and carry on. You consume up to 20 pounds of raw meat at a time,
then go without food for a week.
Their skeletal structure is found in no other animal,
and that combined with their ferocity and complete lack of moral fiber,
make them perhaps our most dangerous enemy.
I rest my case that was no juice,
just propagating hate speech.